عليكم الله الكريمه همم منذ لقاءات لقاءنا
معكم الاول في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في زيارتكم الاولى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من تسعه اشهر تقريبا تم الاتفاق
على التعاون في العديد من القطاعات وتم
انجاز الكثير منها بشكل اكثر ما نتوقع
وهذا نتاكد يؤكد ان فرص بين البلدينا فرص
اكبر بكثير مما كنا نطمح لهذا امر جيد
للقائه فاحنا نعمل اليوم للتحاون في عده
مجالات مجال الطاقه والسياحه والاستثمار
والبنيه التحتيه والزراعه وغيرها المجالات
التي سوف تسير منها بلديه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اول دوله عربيه بلدت علاقه مع
تايلاند في الخمسينيات والان تطلع ان
ننتقل الى مرحله اخرى في العلاقه اليوم
سوف نشهد التوقيع عليه من الاتفاقيات
وايضا سوف نناقش العديد من الفرص في
المستقبل التي سوف نعمل عليها في العام
القادم وانا متاكد انه سوف يكون العائد
على شعبين او على اقتصاد تايلند المملكه
العربيه السعوديه كبير للغايه وفي الاخير
اشكر على حسن الضيافه وحصن استقبال
ورعايتكم الوفد السعودي